KINDF CO-D
>> OF HE LEAD." FROMTL
TO BECOMEN FIRST FORMER PRESIDET
IN A PROSECUTION IN THE
EASTATES.
AN BASH,E THINGS
THHINK WE NEED TO KEEP
LILITOE THM, IS THAT IN
SECOND OF FOUR INDICTMENTSD TRUE
E EXPECT WILL BE FOR
HIEF OVEN THE 2020
ELECTION.
GI THE
OTHER ALSO FRO
CKIN
OW THE JRTCOUNSEL
VEION PL
BUT WHEN IT CO, DE CLET  GS Y S
D SO I BELIEVE LAS
THAT WE'REYBLEAST NDIND
OFNG TS IM
D G ATTZ WHAT IT WAS , LK
OUE FORMERSIDENT'S , TOAVITEALIT
ABHOW ST POLITICS, AS, Y BOMST
FEDERAL CASEHALYARS AMIE GANGEL
THINGS THA'V FM
REPUBLICANS.
>> RIG>>BUT ENOUTALKING ABOUT HU
SAYING T IF THE TRORL BILL
CHARGES IN THE INDICTMENT ARE U.
>> RIGHT
BUT ASREPUBLICANS, WE'VE SEEN,
E SETARY BACKGD SEEMO TAKEO MAYA
ON THE OTHER HAND, W
O PARDONMPR REPUBLICANS, IH O C
BY ENLARGEPUBLICANS ARILL STAND
FUNDRAISING.
COM TO A
POINT --
>> COULD I INTERRUPTOR O EOERIN.
YOU COULD SEE THER A GROUP
TO FAMS RESTAURANT I
MIAMI.
THAT YOU S A GROUP OF TRUMP SUP
R HIM AN M BE GOING INTO
THERE AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS,
WE'LL BRING IT T
BUO  JAMIE
.
>> -- FOR REPUBLICANS
CAMPAIRAW THAT WE'VE SAIIS
TSTIO
HAVE THYE
TH OINT, A FEDER
ELHE COULD HAVE STOPPED IT
TIME BY SIMPLY
DOCUMES.>>TORING TSE
THER, WHAT
NOW IS CLOAK IN THE
LIRRHI ACCOLAD A
PEOPLE WHO LOVE HIM.WELY GOING N
ME WILL FIT
TIME WIT
CE,HAT AR
IN THE INDICTMENREREALITY OF TH
THMEOF AUNT
AND SO OAN
AND THIS IS --OBVIOUSLIS INTENT
S THA
BEEN HAVINA DIUSUTWHETHER OR NO
OF
NAMES ARIR VIEW.
HE'S SAY HERE THAT
SUPPORT ISEA
AMS SUPPORTERS.
LTEIN AS THE
PRESENT SHOW AND -LLE'RE GOIEP .
JOH, THVERSAILL
THN AMERICAN COMMUNITYN MIAMI.
GHS ACTUALLY IN
RANDY, WHAT ARE YO
M AT VERSAILLE
CUBAN RESTAURANT IN LITTLE
. SUCH A CR,
AND THIS WAS AN ANNOUNCED OURT I
VISIT.
>> THAT IS THEOU COULD HEAR R T.
NS OPE WITH THEIR PHONES ALL G
TH I POPULAR
COITAURANTTHE
THIS IS A PLACE WHER 71.
CANDIDA
THE CUBAN VOTE.FEW DECADES TO RP
THESE PEOP AY EXCITED.G TO THEOG
A STOPE DAD  IN FULL SUPPORTF
THEYON
THEY DON'T BELIE IT.
AND THEYT THINK HE'S ASI AND
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE SUPPORTG B.
E DOZENS OLICE
SECRET SERVICE AND A LF
VERY, VERY PONSUPPORTE.
THE PRESIDENT
TO -- THE  TO BE
HE'S SUPPOSED TO GREET SOME OF
WAITINW  SEEMS LIKR S TOEET OHON
OBVIOUSLY ONALD TRP S SUPPORTERD
ANTHS G  HE IS BEEN STN TWO DIF
LOCALES AND IN OTHER PLACE
TRYING TCOHE
POLITICAL PERSECUTN FACED BY
CUBANS BY THE COMMUNITY
GOVERNMENT OF CUBA.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY A PREPO
SUGGESTION COMPARISON.
BUT THRE MAK, JOHN
BY AICRTMENTIS OPPONENT IN THE
THAT IS THE TRUMP ARGUMENT.S AL.
I'
THEY'RE COMING AFTER Y ME,
THAT IS THE WHOLE PERSECUTION
BUT,W -- FOOFO
HE SAID THERE.
UAL HE WANTS.
I JUST LEFT THE COURTHOUSE.
CAMPAIGN.ITAL
GET ON HISLAREDO A FUNDRAISER T
JERSEY AND THEN HE'S GOING TO
I INK WHAT HE SAID TONIG IS  IME
THAT WE SEE HERE.  YOU COULD SE
THERE.
HE'S BEHIND THE GUY WIMIAM
HE'S WITH TH TOWARD
THE LEFT OF YOUR SCREEN.
THAT IS WA NTRUMP'S DANTAL ACCU
OBSTUSTICE AND THE
REMEMBER IT IS A 37-COUNT
MENT.
AND DONALD TRUMP HAS BEE
CHARGED WITH 37 S WITH SIX OF T
CHAR ELI
AND AS WE WATCH DONALD TRUMP
ATTEMPT TO TURRESTINDICTMENT IN
BRE
NATIONAL SECURITY LAWS AND THEN
ONING TOOPERATE WITH THE>> WHATS
AT THIS INDICTMENT
CHS.LD TRUMP ICHS
WI FEDERALNDLING THE
VE GOVERNMENT E HAVE.
US,
S  T  WITH WALT NAUTA WHO ISGEDY
JURYFB
AGAIDESPE
THIS CASN'T BETLED